MALE SPEAKER: I'd like to
welcome Phil Warburg back
to Google to talk about his
book called "Harness the Sun".
He was here earlier to talk
about "Harvest the Wind"
and now we're on to
"Harness the Sun".
As you see he's very interested
in alternative energy
and how it can help
save the climate
and why it's the future of
energy in the United States.
Without further
introduction, I'd
like the invited Phil up to
talk to us about his new book.
PHILIP WARBURG: It's
great to be back at Google
talking about my
favorite subject.
I can't think of a
better place to talk
about technological
transformation than Google.
I want to start by
asking how many of you
have solar on your homes today?
And how many of
you have neighbors
with solar on their homes?
OK, and I want to see
those hands together.
So that really says something
to me about solar power today.
And that is that it's really
become part of our lives
whether we've invested
in it individually
or whether we're part of
a broader community that
has decided that solar is
a worthwhile investment.
And by worthwhile I
mean a number of things.
For some people, that is simply
lowering their electric bills
now and thinking about future
fuel prices and stability
going forward in terms
of their electric bills.
For some, there's
satisfaction in trimming
at least a bit of
their carbon footprint
by generating at least part,
or a substantial part of,
their power from
renewable sources.
And for others
there's a satisfaction
in taking charge of at
least some of the power
that we consume in
our daily lives.
And that latter concept
of taking charge
is one that I found
particularly intriguing
as I traveled the
country talking
to different people about
their own commitment
to moving solar power forward.
One would expect
progressive politicians
like former congressman
Henry Waxman
to be avid solar proponents--
he wrote a wonderful blurb
on the back of my book-- former
Head of the Energy and Commerce
Committee in the
House, dedicated
to environmental issues.
Sea solar as part of
broader panoply of necessary
measures we have
to take to address
the overwhelming challenge
of climate change.
But what was more
surprising to me
was finding that there
is strong support
for solar power among at
least a contingent of very
right-wing libertarians.
People like former congressman
Barry Goldwater Jr.,
he was Congressman
from California
for a number of years,
he now is the chair
of something called
TUSK-- Tell Utilities
Solar Won't Be Killed.
And what that group does is it's
a representation of homeowners
and business owners who
want to generate solar
on their properties and
who want fair compensation
for the surplus power that they
generate and they are fighting
major utilities, such as
Arizona Public Service, which
wants to cut back on the
net metering benefits that
are provided to solar homeowners
and solar business owners.
I don't know if this
is enough to bridge
the gaping political chasm
that exists in America today,
but at least it's a sign that
there is a common language
that we can talk across
the political spectrum
in looking at some of our
renewable energy opportunities.
Back in 2012 when I was just
wrapping up my book on wind
power, people often
asked me, so will
your next book the about solar?
And my kind of flip and
dismissive comment at the time
was that if I ever wrote
a book about solar,
I have to call it "Dim Sun".
And the reason I said that
was because at the time,
it just struck me that
solar was pricing itself out
of the market and was not on the
verge of becoming a mainstream
power producer.
Thankfully, and fairly
quickly, I was proven wrong.
Between the first
quarter of 2012
and the first quarter
of 2015 the price
of residential and utility-scale
solar came down about 46%.
And the price of
non-residential,
as in commercial and public
building related solar,
came down about 52%.
So a very dramatic drop in
a very short period of time.
And another powerful indicator
of just where solar is today
can be found in the first half
of this year's new generation
capacity installations.
Solar, during the first
half of this year,
accounted for 39% of all new
power generation capacity
nationwide.
Wind accounted for about 36%.
So if you add the
two of those, you're
looking at 75% of our new
electric generating capacity
in the first half of this year
coming from renewable sources.
You know we all hear
about natural gas
as the cheaper, more
convenient, accessible options--
and with fracking
ever more accessible.
Gas accounted for
about 21.4% percent
of new generated capacity
during that same period.
So those are all pretty
powerful signs to me
that solar's time
really has arrived.
My own solar journey
began in March of 2013
when my wife and
I decided to put
solar on our own home's roof.
And we actually found ourselves
just a few days after one
of Massachusetts' many
heavy snow storms,
not the likes of which we
saw last year, but 2013
had it's share as well--
and we weren't at all sure
that the installers from
Sunlight Solar Energy
were going to show up
at all, but they did.
And one member of their crew was
a guy named Liam [? Madden. ?]
He was a former Marine
Expeditionary Unit
member in Iraq--
tough guy-- but when
he got out of the gleaming
white Sunlight Solar Energy van
and looked up at our
roof, he kind of blanched.
And I said, what's-- is
something the matter?
Have you not installed solar
on a roof this steep before?
And he said well, actually not.
Our room has a 55 degree slope.
And he and his teammates
climbed the roof
and in utter silence roped
to the peak of the roof,
they installed our solar array.
Thankfully, no one was
hurt and thereafter we've
gotten about 75% of our total
electricity needs from the sun
and that includes
the nightly charging
of a plug-in electric
hybrid vehicle.
So we feel good about what we're
doing and we're by no means
alone in doing this.
There are about 750,000
homeowners and businesses
in America today
who have installed
solar on their rooftops.
During 2014, that
amounted to about one
new solar installation
every 2.4 or 2.5 minutes.
So we're really
again, seeing solar
penetrate the marketplace.
And one thing I should just
mention, which many of you,
given your work in this
particular industry I'm sure
know from electronic appliances,
solar photovoltaics actually
work better in colder weather.
So some people say
well gee, solar
isn't a great match
for Massachusetts,
it's a cold climate,
snowy climate, et cetera.
As long as our solar
panels are clear,
we actually get
better productivity
from the sun during
the winter months
than during the summer months.
Not overall, but at any given
moment, because of the factor
of colder operating conditions.
But we're not just seeing solar
on our homes this I'm sure
is a familiar sight to
you, the Mountain View
headquarters of
Google, where you
have 30% of your peak
electric demand coming
from solar energy, which is
pretty impressive given what
must go on at that complex.
And that might be expectable
because again, you're
a high tech company,
cutting edge, et cetera.
But what's interesting
to me is seeing
how companies like Kohl's,
like Ikea, like Walmart,
are going solar.
Walmart now has solar
on 250 of its buildings
and its goal is to have solar
on 1,000 of its buildings
in the coming years.
They want to be 100% reliant
upon renewable energy
at some point in
the near future.
Walmart isn't exactly
on the cutting edge
of environmentalism or
energy enlightenment,
but in fact, it is working
toward the right ends
in this particular respect.
We're also seeing solar in some
perhaps somewhat unpredictable
places the NFL has made a
commitment to solar there
six NFL stadiums that
either have solar today
or are having it installed
on their facilities.
Gillette Stadium is
one of those places.
I went to witness that
particular facility and I
went-- the first time I went
it was four a Taylor Swift
concert with my two daughters.
I think I was the only
person among the crowds who
was more interested in the solar
arrays than in the performer.
But this particular
facility you're seeing here
is FedEx Field which is
the home of the Redskins.
And this installation
faced a particular problem
and I wonder if any of you
could guess what it might be.
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP WARBURG: Well,
I'll give you a hint.
What's that?
Very close.
Why tailgating?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
on top of the roof.
PHILIP WARBURG: Well, close.
What do people do
at tailgate parties?
They toss footballs.
And so the guy who is
responsible for designing
this facility had to calculate
the arc of a football
when tossed by an
amateur, but still tossed,
to make sure that the
solar parking canopies were
sufficiently above that
arc that footballs wouldn't
come crashing down on the solar
panels on a regular basis.
Not that they probably would
have broken the panels, but not
a real wise idea to have that
constant collision happening.
And beyond the power that
these facilities generate,
those parking canopies are now
the most desired parking spots
at FedEx Field.
On a more practical
level, large warehouses
are beginning to install
solar on their roofs.
New Jersey is a great example.
New Jersey does not have a
huge amount of open space.
It does have a huge amount of
factory space and warehouse
space.
This particular building is
a food storage warehouse.
It's a quarter of a mile long
and it has a huge electric bill
because of the cooling and
refrigeration and freezing
that has to go on
inside this building.
And this building because
of the solar array
now gets 90% of its total
power needs from the sun.
And then if you kind of get
into the real gritty aspects
of solar power's potential, you
have to look at brownfields.
Brownfields for those of you who
are not familiar with the term
are either contaminated or
potentially contaminated
industrial properties.
They could be
former mining areas,
they could be former
factories, they
could be former landfills
or hazardous waste dumps.
And the EPA has a department
called Repowering America's
Land and they have done
a survey of over 100,000
brownfield sites in
America and according
to their calculations,
if we were
to tap the solar potential
on those brownfield sites
we could be getting three
times our total power
needs nationwide.
Now, there are other
challenges in terms
of developing these sites.
You have to rehabilitate
them to a certain degree,
as you can see from
this particular picture.
You're not necessarily
inheriting pristine properties.
But that just bespeaks how
profound an impact solar
could have if we were
to choose hidden and not
so hidden opportunities
for its development.
This particular facility
is on the south side
of Chicago in the West
Pullman neighborhood.
A very crime-ridden area.
Once a big industrial
zone, now largely abandoned
and a site of some pretty
serious local crime.
And Exelon along
came in in 2008,
looked at this plot of land--
it had been an International
Harvester assembly plant
that had been abandoned
in the early 1980s--
and Exelon decided this
would be a good site for solar.
So they installed the
Exelon city solar plant
in the midst of the West
Pullman neighborhood.
They now generate
enough electricity
for about 1,500 households.
I wish I could say
that this it had
some positive impact on
crime in the neighborhood,
unfortunately the major
source of panel breakage
is stray bullets
falling from the sky.
But it did create a
lot of local jobs.
There was a local
metal shop for example
that made all of
the posts on which
these many, many, many thousands
of panels were suspended.
And it turned what
was a safety hazard
and an environmental
hazard and an eyesore
into an economic and
environmental amenity.
We often talk about
solar in terms
of the individual sites that
are prime prospects for solar.
But what's happening is that
entire cities, entire counties
are beginning to look at
solar as a serious strategic
opportunity.
And it would be easy to talk
about a place like Marin
County right across
the Golden Gate Bridge
from San Francisco--
generally upscale.
Marin County developed
something called the Marin Clean
Energy, which is a self-defined
entity that has broken away
from Pacific Gas and Electric
and now purchases power
and sells power
to its customers.
It has a light green option
which is 50% renewable.
It has a dark green option
which is 100% renewable.
It's called community
choice aggregation
and this actually
happens in Massachusetts,
it happens in a number of
localities in California,
and it's happening in
various other states.
So that's, again, the kind of
predictable story about solar.
The less predictable story
about solar I found in a city
called Lancaster, California.
How many of you have
heard of Lancaster?
That's what I thought.
It's a community of about
160,000 people in the middle
of the Mojave Desert.
It was long known as a
center for gang violence
until 2008 when a man named
Rex Paris was elected mayor.
Paris came out of a class-action
litigation background.
Real hard nosed, right wing,
law and order guy, and he
came in saying, I'm going
to clean up this city.
And he proudly told
me that under his rule
20,000 gang members
were put behind bars.
And as he said to me, I don't
care about the Constitution
once you join a gang.
So not exactly warm, fuzzy,
progressive politician.
Thankfully though, that
same dogged determination
that he has applied to
crime-fighting in Lancaster,
he's applied to developing
solar energy in the same city.
Several years ago, he went
to a conference in China
and was sitting
amidst dignitaries
from a number of major
metropolitan centers
and he had his staff with him.
And at a certain
point he felt he
needed to say his own
peace before this crowd,
stood up and declared that
his city was going to become
the solar capital of the world.
And I think his staff's
mouths kind of dropped open
because they weren't quite
prepared for this declaration.
And people kind of
shrugged their shoulders
because who had
heard of Lancaster?
But he came back to California,
the staff set to work,
and over the course
of several years,
Lancaster has developed solar
on most of its public buildings.
It's encouraged local
businesses, such as this Toyota
dealership, to invest in solar.
The local ball field has solar.
Many of the farmlands on
the outskirts of the city
have now built utility-scale
solar facilities.
And every new residential
unit built in the city today
has to either have
solar on its roof
or has to have
off-site solar that
provides at least a
portion of the electricity
for that particular
residential unit.
Paris expects that Lancaster
will be a net solar energy
exporter within the
coming years and I
think he's probably right.
There are plenty of
opportunities for solar
within our built environment.
There are also some
constraints and I encountered
some of those constraints when
I visited my daughter, Maya,
at George Washington University
in the heart of Washington DC.
She took me to what she
regarded as the only evidence
of solar photovoltaics on the
George Washington University
campus and that was this solar
table, which is good enough
to charge a laptop or two or
maybe a few iPhones, but not
much else.
And she wasn't very
impressed with this.
I was less impressed with it.
And we were even
more discouraged
when George Washington
University opened
its brand new high
tech engineering
center-- $300 million LEED
gold certified building.
Solar on the roof?
No.
Why?
Well, the answer I got was
that the District of Columbia
has very strict height limits.
And if they were to put
solar panels on the roof,
they would exceed
those height limits
and they'd have to
knock a floor off
of this very expensive
building, which obviously they
were not willing to do.
So that even impressed
my daughter and me less.
But then came the really
interesting and encouraging
news and that was that
in the spring of 2014,
George Washington
University announced
that it, together with the GW
Medical Center and American
University, would be buying
all the solar output from three
utility-scale solar
farms in North Carolina.
With that purchase, and when
those plants go online in 2017,
GW will be getting over half
of its total power needs
from the sun.
There are lots of other
examples like that.
On the cover of my book and
in the opening to this talk
you saw a picture of
Tempe, Arizona, which
is where Arizona
State University has
about 80 different solar
arrays on its roofs
and it gets 31% of its peak
energy demand from solar power.
And it's a campus that
serves 60,000 commuters.
So again, pretty impressive
solar contribution.
I'm sure various
of you have heard
about the divest of
fossil fuels movements
that have been sweeping
various university campuses.
I think that these universities
are great examples of how they
could-- universities can be
investing in sound alternatives
to fossil fuels, as well as
raising the question about what
their universities
should be investing
in by way of their endowments.
The three North Carolina
solar farms that I mentioned
are examples of utility-scale
solar built on open space.
That open space can
be farmland or it
could be natural open space.
The facility you see here is the
California Valley Solar Ranch.
It is a facility
that now generates
enough electricity for
100,000 California households.
It sits in an area called
the Carrizo Plain, which
some refer to I think,
somewhat generously,
as California's Serengeti.
It does have some wildlife
that the developers
of the California
Valley Solar Ranch
have taken great
pains to protect.
Before constructing the solar
fields at this facility,
a team of biologists
came in and documented
what were the local wildlife
that needed to be protected.
And among them, was
the San Joaquin kit
fox and the giant kangaroo rat.
I have to say I had not
heard of either before I went
to the California
Valley Solar Ranch,
but these are valued species.
And what they did was
they removed these species
from the solar field areas.
They built what they
call temporary condos
for the giant kangaroo rats
and they built temporary dens
for the kit fox and once
the facility was complete,
they allowed these creatures
to re-inhabit the area.
They also built
migratory corridors
so that antelope and elk
could traverse the facility
and not be harmed
and not be disrupted
in their traditional patterns.
And they set aside 12,000
acres in conservation lands
in perpetuity.
So it's an example of a
very large solar facility.
It sits on about
1,400 acres of land,
the solar fields themselves.
But a solar facility
that generates
a lot of power for a lot of
people and where great pains
were taken to protect
wildlife values.
In another community,
the Moapa Paiute
are a tribe in the
southwestern-- southeastern
section of Nevada.
And they had built a large solar
facility, again enough capacity
for about 100,000 households,
and what they encountered
was the desert tortoise.
The desert tortoise is a
threatened species under the US
Endangered Species Act.
That's one level below
being endangered,
but it's worthy of protection.
There about 100,000 of these
creatures left in the southwest
and what the Paiute did was they
collected 75 of these tortoises
from the 2,000 acres where they
were building a solar farm,
fitted them with
tracking devices,
and then relocated them to a
6,000 acre conservation area
10 miles from the facility.
I talked to the chair of the
Moapa Paiute very recently
and he said so far
they've lost one tortoise
and that was to a coyote attack
and that coyote attack could
have happened in the habitat
that these tortoises inhabited
beforehand.
So good examples of great
pains taken to protect wildlife
values on large, open
spaces solar facilities.
How many of you have heard
of concentrating solar power?
So concentrating
solar power relies
upon the thermal properties
of the sun as opposed
to the light
properties of the sun.
And this particular facility
is called Crescent Dunes.
It sits on the
high desert plateau
outside of a former
silver mining town
called Tonopah, Nevada.
It generates enough
electricity for I
think 80,000 or so households
and it uses molten salt
as the vehicle for
capturing the heat that
is focused on the receiving
tower you see there.
It's a 640-foot receiving tower.
That molten salt is heated to
about 1,000 degrees Fahrenheit
and then it is pumped into
storage vessels, giant storage
vessels, where it is held
until the optimal time
to actually use that power.
So what this actually allows
this solar plant to do
is surmount one of the
weaknesses of solar power,
and that is its intermittency.
So they can generate lots
of solar-generated heat
during the daylight
hours and then they
can use that
electricity at night
by converting the
molten salt's heat
into steam which drives a
conventional turbine much
as you use in a gas fired
power plant, for example.
One of the challenges, however,
with concentrating solar power
facilities is that there
is a lot of heat generated
and focused on a very specific
point at the upper end
of this 640-foot tower.
And what happens,
unfortunately, is
that birds that
fly through what's
called the flux-- the very
hot zone-- get killed.
And this is an issue in
Riverside County where
one of these facilities, it's
called [INAUDIBLE] is located.
At the Crescent
Dunes facility, which
is just about to go
into full operation,
they don't expect
the same problem
because there's very little bird
life at that very high plateau
level.
But it's a real issue
and it will be an issue
as we hear about more of
these facilities being
built in the future.
One way to mitigate
the damage to birds
from thermal facilities,
concentrating power facilities,
is to use parabolic troughs
and concentrate the solar heat
on a glass pipe that
you can see there that
runs just a few feet
above the parabolas
and therefore you have a heat
zone where birds are very, very
unlikely to be damaged.
And this is a facility
called Abengoa Solana
in Western Arizona.
These kinds of
facilities are also
being built across the West.
But there are
challenges that we face
as we begin to develop
solar in open spaces.
There are some of the
environmental community who
believes that we need
to go to great lengths
to wean ourselves
off of fossil fuels
and if we're going to do
that using solar energy,
we're going to have to
generate prodigious amounts
of solar power And that is going
to mean that we're not just
going to use solar
in our built areas
but we're going to build
solar in open spaces.
There are land
conservationists who
say, no way, we don't want to
industrialize our landscape.
So that tension is going to grow
in the coming years and decades
as we ramp up solar power and
we see more pressure placed
upon our open spaces.
Which brings me back to talk
about what can we achieve
within our towns and cities?
And the National Renewable
Energy Laboratory,
which is the
government's laboratory
to invest in renewable
energy, did a study
and it's estimated
that we could be
getting a fifth of our total
power needs from rooftop solar
alone.
That's a prodigious
amount of electricity.
That's more than we get today
from nuclear power for example.
Not all homes are
created equal, however.
This is our next
door neighbor's home
and as you can see it's
very heavily shaded
and there isn't much free roof
space where you'd actually
be putting solar panels.
So there are those
kinds of constraints.
And there are also
constraints facing renters.
Boston renters constitute about
60% of the city's households
and on a statewide basis,
renters are about 38.5%
of all households.
Renters don't have
access to their roofs,
or at least they
can't install what
they wish on their rooftops,
so that is a real constraint.
There are other
constraints on rooftops,
such as air conditioning units,
such as in this particular case
a running track on a roof.
So you can't assume
that a roof, even
if it is a substantially
sized roof,
is going to be available
for solar power.
One way to surmount this
particular constraint
is to build what's called
community solar facilities
or shared solar facilities.
These were really
pioneered in Colorado.
This particular facility is
the Venetucchi solar farm.
It has 600 members
who buy shares
in the output of this facility.
Some might buy a share
equivalent to one solar panel,
some might buy a share
equivalent to 10 solar panels.
They in turn get a
proportionate share
of the output of this
facility deducted
from their electric bill.
So this is a great way to
surmount the constraints
that people might
face if they can't
put solar on their own homes.
And we're seeing this
happen in a number of states
and we're seeing it happen a
number of different contexts.
I was in Seattle
a few weeks ago,
and I visited the
Seattle Aquarium
where a rooftop
solar array serves
as a community solar facility.
There are also plans
to develop solar
in Massachusetts
and community solar
so we'll be seeing these kinds
of facilities become available
here in the near future.
There's one other
community that I
want to make sure we
touch upon and that
is low-income communities.
How do we bring solar power
to low income households?
And this is where we haven't
seen enough progress.
California is in the
lead in this area
as it is in so many other
areas regarding solar energy.
It has required that utilities,
the three big utilities,
spent $300 million
installing solar power
on low-income households,
like the household I
visited in the Bay View
district of San Francisco.
The Wang family was a
recent family-- family
of recent Chinese
immigrants and they
qualified for the
low-income solar program.
A group of volunteers
from Salesforce
came in under the supervision
of a nonprofit called
Grid Alternatives and spent the
day installing a solar array
on the rooftop of this home.
And today, the Wang family
gets 90% of its electricity
from the sun, which is
a huge benefit in terms
of its electric bills.
And a big benefit to all of us
in terms of the reduced carbon
footprint of that
particular household.
Just to give you a sense of the
raw potential of solar power
this is a map that was created
using data from the National
Renewable Energy Laboratory.
It was created by
Environment America.
And the states that appear
in red, there 19 of them,
have 100 times or more--
or more than 100 times
the current
electricity consumption
in that state available
as solar potential.
The orange states have
between 25 and 100
times current consumption
available as solar potential.
Massachusetts doesn't quite
stack up in that regard.
We have about two times our
total current consumption
that would be
available from the sun.
But we should all be proud
that in fact Massachusetts
is doing very well
compared to other states.
It's a small state, but
we're generate-- we're
number five in the nation.
And we-- as you can see,
are in the winner's circle
with California,
Arizona, New Jersey--
again industrial state, but
making ample opportunity--
ample use of the
built environment
to install solar power--
and North Carolina.
I should mention, by the way,
that some people again think,
well Massachusetts
isn't prime for solar.
The top solar producer
in the world is Germany.
Germany gets about 7% of its
total power needs from the sun
and it is a cloudy, rainy
climate by and large.
It has an average of 1,500
sunlight hours per year.
Boston gets about 2,600--
more than 2,600 hours
of sunlight per year.
So we have a lot of
potential that we
could tap as part
of a broader attempt
to move away from fossil fuels
and toward renewable energy.
We have a number of pro-solar
solar policies in the state.
I'm not going to go through
all of them right now,
but we can discuss them
in the Q&A if you'd like.
But I think what we
have to recognize is
that solar potential is huge.
Opposition to
solar is also huge.
Utilities are very nervous
about solar penetration
for a variety of reasons.
They're particularly
concerned about distributed
solar generation, because
they make their money
by selling kilowatt hours.
And that's a fairly
simplistic model.
You build a coal plant,
you turn on a coal plant,
you generate electrons, you
sell the kilowatt hours.
What is being
demanded of them today
is that they become much
more flexible energy services
providers that might be involved
in storing energy, that might
be involved in various kinds
of smart metering, energy
efficiency.
And if they don't want to go
the route of Kodak and Polaroid,
they're really going to have to
become much more nimble, much
more diversified
energy providers.
Fossil fuel companies
are fighting hard
against pro-solar policies
at the federal level
and at the state level.
So we've got to reckon
with them as well.
But I think that we all need
to look at the bigger picture
and embrace the opportunities
that solar presents.
Reckon with some of the
legitimate questions
that are being raised.
But the profundity
of the transformation
that we're going
to have to undergo
is going to involve
some trade offs.
There is no such
thing as clean energy.
There's cleaner energy
and dirtier energy.
And solar offers some
huge opportunities,
some huge
environmental benefits,
and some personal
satisfaction, such
as I described
earlier in my talk.
I just wanted to invite
you to join my family
in reading "Harness the Sun".
I call this picture
"Harnessing the sun while
sitting in the shade".
Thank you all for coming
and happy hear comments
and questions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So looking
around the room,
I think I'm one
of the few people
[INAUDIBLE] marketing
side of Google.
But I actually [INAUDIBLE]
marketing problem.
I get ads all the time
from natural gas groups
and frequently see
a lot in the market
for an uninformed
consumer, letting
them know about other
alternatives that
aren't related to solar.
And I'm wondering what you're
opinion is on why that may be.
Why there isn't being more
done from just a pure marketing
standpoint to show off the
benefits of solar and the cost
[INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP WARBURG:
You're saying, who
are the marketers per say,
you mean the telemarketing
that we're getting?
AUDIENCE: No,
literally, I'll see ads
on TV or on YouTube for
why natural gas is great.
It's probably lobbyist, I'm not
sure what groups are behind it.
You don't-- all the benefits
that we know about--
how much cheaper it can be and
all the different things like
that don't come out for
something like solar.
PHILIP WARBURG: Well, first
the fossil fuel industry
has huge resources to draw
upon in terms of marketing.
They've been doing
it for decades.
One of the advantages
they have is
that they have a fairly
unquestioned panoply
of federal and state subsidies
that they've been getting
for decades and decades.
And I think what's
happening with solar
is it's the new entrant onto the
scene, along with wind power,
and everyone is scrutinizing it.
So the incentives for solar,
the incentives for wind,
are questioned and become
political footballs in Congress
in a way that the
subsidies for oil and gas
and nuclear and coal do not.
I think that's a
serious problem.
I think solar marketers
are getting more and more
proactive, more and more.
Sophisticated I have to say,
and we were talking over lunch,
I get several calls a week
from solar companies wanting
to put solar on my
roof and I politely
tell my have solar on my roof.
And Jason was saying that he
gets calls from solar companies
and he politely tells them he
can't put solar on his roof
because it's too shaded.
I think that we're seeing a
fairly robust, competitive,
climate right now for solar.
One of the interesting
things about solar
is that there are lots
and lots of players.
There are small players,
like Sunlight Solar Energy
which installed our
facility, very small company.
It has annual revenues of
about $10 million a year
on up through SolarCity.
And it's a very,
very new industry.
As I said, I myself
wasn't convinced in 2012
the solar was something
to be taken seriously.
Three years later,
solar is a buzz
in all kinds of
technology circles.
We're seeing the
technology itself
improve very dramatically.
And I think it needs
some smart marketing
acumen applied but I think it
really is beginning to happen.
AUDIENCE: I guess I was thinking
more about the branding of it.
So not of individual-- someone
saying I want to install it,
but just the
concept of it, which
it may just be a resources
thing or industry [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP WARBURG: I think
some of the bigger numbers
need to get out there so that
people recognize it's not just
at the margins.
So for example, the National
Renewable Energy Laboratory
does great research.
That research
doesn't necessarily
get the circulation it should.
One of their studies that I
find particularly interesting
is called Renewable
Electricity Futures
and it came out in 2012.
And projected that using
technology that is commercially
available today,
we could be getting
half of our total
powered needs by 2050
from the wind and the sun alone.
So that kind of
statistic says to me,
these are serious part-- these
are serious technologies that
could really transform the way
we think about the energy we
use and the energy we produce.
And I think people have to
be attuned to those messages
when they do get covered.
They do get covered probably
in the higher brow media, maybe
not in the broader
maybe, I'm not sure.
I think solar has one advantage
and that is its immediacy
and that people can
relate to the fact
that solar is happening again by
just looking at their neighbors
roofs.
It's not some remote
concept out there
that they don't
really understand.
It's palpable and it is within
our reach quite literally.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What might you say to
someone like Jason or others--
my roof I have slate
and doesn't quite
point the right direction.
There's lots of challenges.
A community-based one
that you had mentioned
might be great for
something like that.
But how do you-- are
there groups that
are helping to initiate that?
To find space?
To help provide the
funding mechanisms-- Again,
PHILIP WARBURG: It is just
starting up in Massachusetts
so I think you will be
hearing a lot more about it
in the next year.
And if you ask where
it's happening,
you might just find that there
is a community solar facility
that you can invest in.
There is a problem in that
again, between 22% and 27%
of residential roof tops
are well suited to solar.
You happen to be in that other
majority which is unfortunate,
but there are opportunities.
What's happening prospectively
I think is interesting.
Our building stock turns over
on average every 42 years.
So we're not just talking about
how do we introduce solar today
and tomorrow and next year.
We're talking about how do
we create a wholly different
orientation-- and I
mean that both literally
and figuratively-- so
that we incorporate solar
much more fully into our lives.
Madison, Wisconsin is an
example of a city that
requires that new
residential areas be designed
on an east-west north-south
grid so that houses can be
built that will be solar-ready.
They're not yet saying
you must build solar,
but they're saying
that the overall layout
of new communities has
to be amenable to solar.
And we're seeing
that kind of thing
happen in a lot of
different localities.
In some localities
they are actually,
as I said, mandating
that solar be installed.
I think with some older
houses that have slate,
with houses that are
shaded, there are trade offs
that one has to consider.
When is your roof
going to be replaced?
Is that tree a tree that
you cherish or is it
a tree that you would rather
sacrifice to the solar cause?
And there are great
advantages to shade trees
in the summertime so you don't
want to be foolish and cut down
a tree only to
generate solar power
to fuel the air conditioning you
have to use because you don't
have a shaded house anymore.
So those are the kinds
of considerations
that I think you have to weigh.
Did I see another hand in here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was wondering what
your thoughts are on
needing to store energy
to make solar [INAUDIBLE]?
PHILIP WARBURG: I
think that goes back
to the question of what is the
function that our utilities
play today and what function
do we play in generating
power and storing power.
I'm sure you've all been hearing
about the power wall that
is being proposed or already
being marketed on a household
level, on a business level.
One can begin to store
solar power on those levels.
There are also much larger
means of storing solar power.
For example, pumped
hydro storage
is a great way to capture a
lot of surplus electricity
when let's say
the sun is shining
or when you have major
wind farms producing
huge amounts of wind power
in the middle of the night
when no one needs that power.
So if you can pair
those facilities
with a pumped storage facility,
pump the water into a storage
reservoir, release that water
when the power is needed,
you have a great
storage resource.
I think we also have to
just get much, much smarter
about how we manage
our own use of energy
and that has to do with
the lights in this room,
has to do with computers
in our household,
it has to do with
industrial refrigeration,
heating and cooling,
where utilities could be playing
a much more significant role,
where Google I'm sure we'll be
playing a much more significant
role in helping us manage our
energy use in a wiser and more
energy-conserving
and better timed way
so that it actually does sync
with the power resources that
are available.
One other resource I
should mention, by the way,
is car batteries.
If we had a fleet of tens of
millions of electric vehicles
your average car is driven
let's say 20-- an hour
a day, half hour day,
hour and a half a day.
So you have the vast
majority of the day
when your car is sitting
idle and that battery could
be used to charge
your car or it could
be used to de-charge
and in fact fill in some
of the bumps in the
electric power grid
if there was a well-integrated,
smartly coordinated use
of that battery resource.
The great thing
about that is you're
not just creating
battery as storage,
you're creating
battery as mobility
and it also serves
a storage function
when the car isn't being
used for mobility purposes.
So again, I think
there's no single answer
and I think we've
got to move away
from the kind of monofix
that is going to solve
our future energy problems.
There isn't a monofix It's
going to be a much more
complex environment,
a smarter environment,
and one hopefully that
is much more reliant
upon renewable resources.
Yes?
Is there still aggressive
tax subsidization
of installation in
public technologies
the way there was we were
seeing three, four, five
or is that largely [INAUDIBLE]?
PHILIP WARBURG: There is a
federal investment tax credit.
I wouldn't use word aggressive.
I would say perhaps,
AUDIENCE: --Massachusetts.
PHILIP WARBURG: --robust.
OK.
First, on the
federal level there
is an investment tax credit.
A 30% tax credit available
for solar installers and that
can be at the
utility level, it can
be at the non-residential
level, and it can
be at the residential level.
That tax credit is slated
to sunset at the end of 2016
entirely for
residential properties
and it will drop
from 30% percent
to 10% for non-residential
and utility scale solar.
That will have a very,
very serious impact
on the solar industry.
In a number of states there
are a number of incentives
that are being phased back.
There used to be much
higher solar rebates
for example in Massachusetts.
They had been phased
way down and that's
true in a lot of other states.
There are tradeable credits
called solar renewable energy
certificates that
are still in effect,
although the Massachusetts
legislature is considering ways
to phase them out
in future years.
I think any energy technology
requires an incentive
to get it off the ground.
And I think what troubles me
when people hyper scrutinize
the solar subsidies
is they're not again,
looking at the playing field
that solar has to play on.
We're talking about royalties
on mineral extraction
in America that are among
the lowest in the world.
We're talking about all
kinds of depletion allowances
and other benefits
to the oil industry.
We're talking about an act
called the Price-Anderson Act
Act that allows nuclear
reactors basically
to function in this country.
It sets a cap of half a billion
dollars per reactor accident
as the liability limit for a
reactor owner and operator.
The rest is covered by
the federal government.
Without that cap, civilian
nuclear would go nowhere.
And so we're not talking
about a level playing field
and we are talking
about creating
some incentives to jump start
an industry, which is really
in its infancy.
And we have to think about why
we're so interested in moving
a sustainable energy
technology forward
and build from
there toward well,
what are the steps we need to
take to integrate it more fully
into our economy?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just to add to the
point that you just made,
the [INAUDIBLE] published
study a couple of months ago
which said that G20 countries
pay over $1,000 per citizen
in fossil fuel subsidies
and in the United States
it's $2,000 per
citizen which I think
dwarfs any of the
solar subsidies.
PHILIP WARBURG: That's
a great example.
There is a lot of
debate right now about
whether solar
homeowners are cross--
are being cross-subsidized
by average rate payers.
And there may be some
of that going on.
There's a lot of
studying going on
as to whether there needs to be
some adjustment in net metering
pay regime.
And we'll see adjustments
being made going forward
but I think it's very
important, again, to give people
an incentive to go into
a frontier technology
that people might have
apprehensions about
and where you break down
some of that resistance
by helping people recognize
some of the economic benefits
of moving towards solar energy.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
a sense of the chance
that the federal [INAUDIBLE]
is going to be renewed
or is it gone?
PHILIP WARBURG: My
guess is that what
we might see is a more graduated
phasing out of the-- right now
it's a pretty radical 30% to
zero for residential solar
and 30% to 10% for the others.
I would hope we'd at least see
a more gradual phasing down
of that incentive, but
the whims of Congress
are a little hard to predict.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
One of the early slides
if you could have shown--
the cost of installing
is going down
for residential
and non-residential
on the utility scale.
With that in mind, is it
much more cost-efficient
to invest in community
solar than to have everybody
put it up on their own?
PHILIP WARBURG: One of the
advantages of community solar
is you can choose
an optimal site.
And because you're
building a larger
scale per installed
panel, it is cheaper.
So yes, there are
cost benefits there.
Utility scale is also-- is
cheaper still, much cheaper
still.
You have the issue of
transmission right?
Because if you're building
one of those large facilities
like the California
Valley Solar Ranch,
you've got to transmit
that power from that ranch
into the grid and
to, in that case,
I think it's the LA
Department of Water and Power
where that power is ultimately
going to be consumed.
So larger scale does allow
for more efficient citing.
One of the things that is--
we're waking up to a little bit
is we're not just
talking about what are
called the hard cost of solar.
We're not just talking about
the cost of the panels,
or of the inverters.
We're talking about the
soft costs, marketing costs,
the permitting costs.
And what we have found
is that Germany-- one
of the reasons German solar
is cheaper per installed watt
than American solar is
because the soft costs are
a fraction-- they're about
10% percent of our soft costs
because they've gotten very,
very effective about marketing
and very expedited about their
permitting of solar facilities.
So there are opportunities
to economize on solar they
we're just beginning to tap.
AUDIENCE: Do you see--
you put up also the map
of the red and yellow states.
Do you see one of these
red states just coming
forward and doing what
the mayor of Lancaster did
and saying we're just
going to export solar
to the whole country.
And Nevada has basically
an eastern border
and a western border and there's
not a whole lot in between
[INAUDIBLE]?
PHILIP WARBURG: That's to some
degree happened with wind.
Where if you look at Iowa,
Iowa now generates about 28%
of its total power from wind.
It has decided that wind is an
important export commodity, as
well as a commodity that's
being used within its borders.
Same thing with Wyoming.
In the case of
solar, my guess is
we're going to see a more even
distribution across a variety
of different contexts.
I think that that tension that
I described between open spaces
protection and
solar exploitation
will lead us to rely
upon farmland-based solar
much more than on natural
spaces based solar.
And if you look at
our country-- I'm
sure you've all flown
across the country--
and you see the grid
of farmed America,
there are huge, huge parts
of the country that it would
be very hard to call natural.
And so I think if you're talking
about converting a soy field
or corn field or an
alfalfa field to solar,
you're talking about a very
different kind of wildlife
versus renewable
energy trade off
than you are if you're
talking about open desert land
where there are species
that people are very
concerned about protecting.
One opportunity I think
it's in California where,
as of 2013-- I couldn't
find the number for 2014--
but as a 2013, more than a
quarter of a million acres
were still in
cotton cultivation.
Cotton is a water
intensive crop.
It's not an essential food crop.
It's expensive to
grow in California.
There's one huge
solar opportunity
and the rate of solarization in
California is terrific as well.
So I think if we
look at farmlands--
and we're seeing
farmlands developed
in places like
Maryland, for example--
one of the advantages, by the
way of solar photovoltaics as
compared to concentrating
solar power is
that you can locate solar
fields that are not necessarily
immediately adjacent
to one another.
So if you have scattered
corn fields with forest land
in between you could build
the solar on those cornfields
and protect the forest lands.
You can't really do that with
concentrating solar power
because you need a
very large area where
you are focusing all of that
heat energy on the receiving
tower.
So I think plenty
of opportunities.
More likely on what you
could call degraded lands,
as in farmlands
or, again, looking
at brownfield properties
than on natural open spaces.
Maybe one more question.
AUDIENCE: The place that I
see would be ideal for putting
these is parking lots.
Like you were saying
at the stadium,
it's a great place to
park-- it can give you
shade and protection from rain.
PHILIP WARBURG: Right.
AUDIENCE: Any chance of
developing those more?
PHILIP WARBURG: Yeah, I
mean they are developing.
The cover my book has
a large parking garage
at the Tempe Campus at
Arizona State University.
Rutgers University at
its Livingston Campus
has major parking
canopies built as well.
The NFL stadiums are
using that same approach.
It's a great opportunity.
It is more expensive
per unit for example
than ground-mounted
solar because you
have to build the
superstructure which
is a larger superstructure
than simply building the row
after row of solar panels.
But it's certainly
a huge opportunity.
And a lot of people for example,
when they look at New Jersey,
and they say,
look, we don't want
to encroach upon our farmland,
we have little enough of it
left, they say, look
at parking lots.
And look at warehouse
roofs and those
are certainly opportunities
that we could exploit.
Thank you all very
much for coming.